[Music]
as
folks enter welcome my name is will
torres i'm one of the admission officers
at the stanford graduate school of
business i
am so excited to be hosting this panel
from africa to stanford our goal today
is to talk about all of those things in
that early stage of the process
how were you thinking about business
school what was the transition like
what were those first few weeks like and
how can we make sure that we're
providing
as much information to everybody out
there on the different journeys that
people take
to stanford so that once they're here
you're able to thrive
eyes wide open and really reach for
those things that help you lead a life
of meaning and a career of purpose
when you come to stanford you're going
to be joining a global community in this
year's graduating class of 2021
joshua i see you congratulations on your
impending graduation
we had 43 international students so it
really
is a community of folks from all over
the world
uh this class represented 66 countries
over
70 languages spoken some of the most
exciting things too is
what's happening how do we support some
of these voices and experiences
so that people are really able to learn
and engage across
all of these different lived experiences
clubs and organizations are definitely a
huge part of that
for this crowd in particular the africa
business club might be of interest
bringing together professional and
personal and community um
regardless of where in the world that
you're thinking of going and especially
for those thinking about returning to
the continent
there's also our um middle east north
africa club
bringing together a lot of folks from
the greater mena region to
celebrate many of those destinations
people and cultures
there's an international committee in
our student government
as well as a dei council where folks are
able to get involved
and a bechtel international center so
bechtel international center
serves our greater stanford university
and
our pretty big international community
so for everything from
visa questions to internship
opportunities they are going to be a
great
resource to help direct you to all the
different needs that
folks from international backgrounds
might be looking for
while they're at the gsb so
let's go ahead and get started and get
to meet our panelists
so we'll go from left to right you could
tell us a little bit uh
share your name where you're from and a
little bit about
maybe one of your favorite classes while
you're at the gsb
so uh michelle if we can get started
with you please
sure um hi everyone really nice to
to be here today um so my name is
michelle i'm originally from kenya
but i've been in the u.s for oh wow
almost
15 years i think at this point so i
first came here for for undergrad i went
to haverford college
and then i worked in new york in
consulting and
in banking before applying to to
business school
um a class that i really enjoyed
while i was at gsb this one is going to
be a bit cliche but
you know touchy philly i think is
definitely up there um
it's more around and i think that the
official name is interpersonal dynamics
and so it's really around how you impact
others how you provide feedback and how
you
essentially make yourself more
vulnerable so you can form deeper
relationships and it's something that i
try to apply both in my personal life as
well as my professional life so
that's been i think uh a class that's
had a lasting impact for me
yeah michelle was there like a aha
moment or a particular learning that
um continues to sit with you today
um i think the easiest way to summarize
um
my takeaways from that class is you have
to be willing to open yourself up if
you're going to form deeper
relationships with people
and i think um especially coming from
from kenya i think in a lot of african
countries that's not necessarily how
we're brought up
um especially in terms of like how we
share our emotions
how you interact with leaders how you
interact with older people
um but especially when you think about
the culture in the us even the corporate
culture
a lot of it is starting to move towards
welcoming more of that vulnerability
in the corporate workplace in the
workplace in in terms of building
leadership skills and building
relationships across the organization so
um so that's why i think i think about
that class a lot nice thank you aviolun
you can go ahead and introduce yourself
please
um hello everyone uh my name is abiodun
worry
i'm from nigeria and then
i actually had my undergrad years at the
university university of ibadan nigeria
so after that i did industrial
engineering and after that
i walked a bit in lagos all my all my
career in lagos
uh power to stanford uh just be and i
applied directly from
lagos nigeria so i've never been to the
us
prior to going from stanford to south
took me to the us
for the very first time i was a
beautiful experience
and then at stanford i think one class i
really found really
interesting i found really interesting
uh is
managing and growing enterprise and
also you know scaling i think somewhere
around them
scaling high impact um ventures
in emerging markets uh those two classes
were a bit
really good for me uh the first one
because we actually
deal with real life cases that real life
issues
that you could you know encounter doing
your
you know organizational growing doing uh
growing your organization as you said
now the other one talks about
gives you it's more like startup garage
gives you
allows you to develop a an idea
and then use yourself and your
classmates to actually do
uh develop the idea in class and also go
as far as you know testing your ideas in
in in
in markets so it was a bit um i worked
on tech then
because i had passion of you know trying
to use technology to
uh you know deliver quality education to
you know less and less privilege and
also that for me was also another class
i really i found
really really interesting so that's it
for me for now
uh maybe uh just so i can take it out
nice
yeah joshua take it away thanks boy
um yeah hi everyone nice to meet you
i'm joshua i'm like um
you do i my undergrad was in nigeria
bought
in the better school of performia oil
our university not quite
45 minutes away
so i was a clinician and an academician
in kanu so i worked at the i mean can
teaching hospital and
lectured at the bairo university and i
had veered into public health earlier in
search of
broad impact and then realized that
i also wanted to focus on
[Music]
contributing to capital allocating
decisions because that would even
allow me further impact which is why i
decided to
apply for the mba so i applied
again from nigeria um from kanu
so not labor's like um
[Music]
classes that i've enjoyed at the gsd
where do i
start um i know i'm forced to pick
just one and uh i've enjoyed many of the
classes that uh michelle
and bill do have spoken about but i
think one that stands out to me
is osm so the optimization and
simulation modeling
i've always loved numbers i had to
forget about those becoming a doctor not
really
but um um i guess now i had to engage
with it
in a more german manner but i think what
actually resonated with me was the fact
that
if you really think deeply about it you
can convert
almost every qualitative problem to a
quantitative
issue and that actually helps with um
decision making
and that has flown uh or flowed into a
course i'm taking now
um corporate financial modelling with
dimaso which i absolutely love because
it brings the qualitative and
quantitative part of business together
and makes it real
for you so i'd say that's the streak
that i've
enjoyed a lot here at stanford nice and
then you you are thinking about going
from the healthcare world to
to the finance world correct yes
so um like i said i had gone into public
health
um hoping to affect the socio-economic
determinant of disease
not just the symptoms of the diseases i
was treated
but realized very quickly that
everything needed to be paid for
and the current impact models we had
that is philanthropy
or policy or waiting for capital markets
to
efficiently distribute resources and be
able to tackle things like climate
change and co
i realized that it was just ineffective
so the fastest way to do that
would be for somebody like me who had
policy competencies who had worked in
government who had worked in the
non-profit world to actually be
where capital allocation decisions were
being made and that literally means
finance
so yes i do hope to end up in
development finance stroke impact
investing
someday and that's why i came for the
mba program
nice yeah all right so i'm gonna stop
sharing screen so we'll be able to focus
on each other
and so folks continue to submit
questions
one of you so usually you are already
beating me to the punch with my first
question
and so i'm gonna ask it through the lens
of our q a box here
user says thank you very much for the
session so thank y'all our panels for
joining us
for abiodun maybe we can start with you
with this question
and then for our other panelists i'll
i'll ask you follow-ups
with a slight adjustments but how
difficult was it to adapt to life in the
u.s especially in those first days
given that you you just mentioned like
this was the first time you came to the
us
uh well uh at first uh you know i came
with the zeal of like oh if i could
succeed in india
i think i can succeed anywhere in the
world i came with that
mentality but to be very honest the very
first
few days were a bit challenging i have
to put it out there
uh challenging because you know there
were
language barriers not in terms of the
fact that maybe understanding of english
but more around the essence uh to which
people around and
even the professors were you know were
speaking so i find it difficult to
understand
really deeply water you know uh i find
it's going to flow
in cars a bit so uh it was a bit
challenging plus the fact that the
volume of
you know materials i have to read to
each person
so each class is really voluminous
compared to
how we used to study back um in nigeria
so it was it was really challenging but
then
uh the i think what um what got you into
stanford in the first place is the fact
that
you have the ability to definitely you
know improve
in no time and with the support of the
uh
the student and uh the uh what you call
audio called you call it now
uh the the they support the student
support
service part of gsb were really helpful
in the sense that we had to do uh focus
groups for example
where people speak uh you know and then
uh if i don't understand i tell them to
slow down a bit and then i get the
message you know and
they were really helpful within within
that same quarter i was able
to definitely get you know myself on
track back you know but the first few
days were a bit challenging
one of i sent uh you know shock i would
say
and then the other one is like you know
the volume of work that you have to go
through
and then also the fact that the last
time is a bit different i was used to
for example local foods are coming from
nigeria
and they have to go to uh
and all that every day so that was all
that like very huge difference i have to
like
try to adjust to so those are like the
experience um those were the experiences
that in the early days
but i think they pretty much set me up
for success eventually
thank you so you you mentioned some of
the student support and
actually joshua you are one of our peer
mentors
can you tell start us and tell us a
little bit about that program
and then i'll come back to like what
your transition felt like coming to the
gsb
sure i can do that so i think the
thinking
behind the peer mentor program is that
peer-to-peer support
can be often times highly effective when
it comes to tackling
sometimes common concerns but sometimes
even more esoteric ones
and somebody who has walked in the shoes
that you are going to feel this may be
able to give you cogent
ideas and advice on tackling some of
these things and so i was selected
um along with 11 other awesome people to
be
pay mentors for the 20 20 21 um session
um and i personally interacted with
say around 35 mentees because we were
two
peer mentors per section and then each
section had 70 people
so um i'd say we were able to develop
a deep connection sometimes deep
friendships
i was able to help with advice
concerning
academics concerning
interaction with other classmates with
those in mba 2 networks career searches
and just generally be a resource
whenever the incoming student wanted to
um tap on that resource um the program
has been reformatted a little bit
but it still remains and i think that
the reformer team is going to position
it for even
um greater experts so that's actually a
great resource
um for those coming from more different
contexts um um to the gsb
to be able to tap into and um use it to
acclimate
nice and then joshua you had multiple
other graduate experiences how would you
compare
uh the gsb and business school to some
of those experiences so
because i know some folks in our
attendees group might be also be coming
from
other graduate programs that is such a
as such an interesting question and for
context
i completed the graphic program in
medicine so i completed the residency
and then fellowships after that
i also started um don't know if i'm
going to complete a phd
that was um somewhere in netherlands and
then i have a master's in public health
from
the east coast and the school that
spells down from backwards
so so yes i do have quite a few graduate
experiences
some say too much school um
how stanford and the business school
compares to it i'd say
very favorably and maybe this is
recently
speaking but if i could go along
maybe some attributes
i'd say in terms of one inclusivity
i think that stanford does a wonderful
job
of being very intentional on how to
create
um community within
and even outside what you'd consider
your normal bubble
[Music]
two i think stanford does a good job of
accommodating different learning styles
now many of the other places i was in
it's either
the way or the highway but here
there's if there's a huge focus on
multi-disciplinary learning so are you
using seminar style
formats are using didactic do you prefer
your visual learner
are you a more verbal learner and
stanford does a very good job
of that three sheer amount of resources
here
i think is unrivaled worldwide and that
might
be on a per capita basis because
you know there's a smaller class size
but i do
think the choice of cluster is also
intentional to be able to
ensure that you're almost buried in
resources
and that's um fantastic and if you're
coming from africa like me
and you don't really like cold there's
something to be said about the wonderful
weather
in california yeah so i could go on
and on but this just gives you a sense
of
how i think stanford compares to many of
the other programs that
i've been in it's it's i think many
people could learn from stanford
and then michelle you did your undergrad
here in the us
um how does uh did your undergrad
compared to a graduate program knowing
that you went to
haverford a liberal arts college in
philadelphia on the east coast
can you talk a little bit about how
those two experiences might compare and
what things
folks who might also be attending a
small liberal arts school could expect
coming to like a school like the gsb
um yeah so it's it's funny i'm trying to
think back and it makes me feel like it
was like
decades ago at this point um but
i think the biggest difference is well
maybe let me start with the similarities
i think the similarities is haverford
was a pretty small school
so overall the entire student body was
something like a thousand students
um you know gsb each class is about 400
so times two you're getting about 800.
so the size of the communities
are pretty similar but i think what i
would say the biggest differences are
is one you know when you go into
undergrad
you're you're just at a different point
in your life right you're probably
that's the first time maybe you've left
your parents home and so it's a very
foreign environment for a lot of
a lot of people i think even the even
the people who are maybe based locally
it's like the first time you're really
in a different environment from your
home environment
and so i remember for me because i was
my first time coming to kenya it was
very similar to a building i think
that's when i had to deal with
the issues around like accents and being
heard
and getting used to the class
environment
how you how great how grading is done
here the relationships that you have
with your professors that's where i
think i had my culture shock
and so as a result i think when i went
into into business school it didn't feel
as much
of a tough transition as i think
undergrad did for me
i think the other difference that i
would call out is because you're sort of
in a different
point in your life right when you get
into business school you have
you have some work experience for a lot
of people
uh you've worked you know anywhere
between two to four years you've been
out in the world you've essentially
earned your own money in some cases
and so your your approach to both the
academic and social environment in
business school is very different so
business school is a lot more social
it's a lot more network focused it's a
it's a lot more focused around how
you're building longer-term
relationships with your classmates
whereas i think undergrad is more
academic in in nature in terms of the
focus
um and so i think at the end of the day
what
what i enjoyed about both both
experiences is
you know because they're small you do
have that closeness that joshua
mentioned right
the community the inclusiveness um but
because you're at different points in
your life what you get out of
um a business school environment is is i
think
more longer term in terms of your
network
in your career than than probably um
undergrad
just based on my experience nice and
then so this next question maybe we can
start with you
as well michelle so the question comes
from kashira
who has a question about the mba
experience how did it change or
impact your perception of how you view
business in africa
um earlier you mentioned um some of the
different like cultural elements and how
you interact with others
can you tell us a little bit more about
that michelle and then we'll open it up
to the panel
yeah so i would say one of the reasons i
actually was really excited to go to
to stanford once i got in is because i
think stanford is one of the
few business schools in the us that is
taking a very
let's call it like mature partnership
type of approach to how they think about
african businesses
and i think we see this both in terms of
the classes so there's a lot of you know
just case studies that are focused on
african countries i remember like my
first strategy class was on equity bank
which is like one of the biggest banks
in kenya
um there's a lot of classes focused
around how you navigate
um some of the tougher sort of
regulatory environments that we tend to
see in a lot of african countries as
well
and then of course there's the seed seed
network
that is a program at stanford that works
directly to support
building leadership and business skills
with
african companies and they have a
presence i believe in in ghana they have
a presence in in kenya and they work
with
a cohort of compa of companies um
every every year and so being able to
tap into all of those resources
during my business school experience for
me was fantastic because even though i
hadn't necessarily spent a lot of time
working on the continent it gave me a
sense for what that could look like
because i'm learning more about the ins
and outs of like strategy making within
african countries
exploring these regulatory environments
and then with the seed
network specifically i had a chance to
do an internship with a nigerian company
so
i was able to work with a nigerian
makeup company the summer before
between first and second year which was
just a fantastic experience because
um one you're kind of then in the heart
of like a business
on the continent you get to see the ins
and outs you get to see the challenges
and you get to learn from like the most
senior leaders in that company
um and so before business school you
know the idea of
let's say moving back home and engaging
in business
uh was in my mind i think being able to
then explore that
fully within the business school
experience in in you know in class as
well as like on the ground
within internships made it a lot more
real so that as i think about like
long term what could moving back home
look like
i feel like i have a much better
understanding now uh versus before where
it was i think a lot more theoretical
yeah speaking of moving back home we
have someone who did it on the panel so
maybe aviono can you tell us a little
bit about like did the gsb
um how did that shape your view of kind
of working back
back on the continent and how does it
continue to
um kind of impact your work today
uh so i tell you this so currently um
i'm a special assistant to the cabinet
state governor
uh malam is excellency
and i basically focus on economic
matters
i i feel uh just be literally set me up
for success
in that aspect to be honest so while at
gsb i focused a lot more on the
social innovation i took a lot of these
traditional classes and i
the certificate for public management
and social innovation
so that set me up for that line of uh my
line of um career and um after grad i
actually
you know walked a bit in the u.s with a
faint type complaint
and then even while working there i was
very
open to you know doing something that
impacts like the
uh the continent directly and when i
knew the opportunity was going to come
it was only a matter of time
so when it came you know and then
i just grabbed it and i moved back and
because the governor author
actually also you know i assured me of
uh you know things are gonna be fine
i'm gonna be able to work on programs
that can really see the impact
and a lot of that have actually
accomplished a little bit more you know
and what um stanford mba is
still doing right now for me my career
is that it's setting me apart from
every other person around to be honest
like i have a better
you know understanding of problems i
have better you know
uh better idea generate the generation
system and i also you know shown out
like really quality work that have been
talked about
in every part of the of the government
of the government
government office so pretty much kind of
like you put you in a position where
you can actually go far you know not
only in business
but in other parts of
another part of the areas that you might
eventually choose to go to
for example we they are classes with our
beyond the market class for example
i give you an idea of what really is the
role of government
or non-market state actors
in ensuring successful uh ensuring the
success of
uh businesses in a particular territory
so for me for now if i'm i've related
with a couple of
businesses so for example we're just
building this very
huge uh mall in in town and then we have
to really get
investors like if um like um retail
stores and all that
and i really have to work with them to
ensure that they succeed they actually
set up
open and succeed because that's where
you get the benefits and a lot of how i
was able to do that was from the class
like for example beyond the
market class that we did at stanford so
really uh you all you know you you give
me the awareness that as a government
your role is not to stiffen
a business um environment but to enable
them to
grow and then nourish them to become
billion-dollar brands
around so it's been it's been a really
interesting experience working back home
and he has actually opened even a lot
more doors to be honest so for example
the the um actually got admitted to the
mpp program at oxford and then the state
government is sponsoring my attending
the masters in public policy program at
10 university of oxford for example
so these are the things that you get
benefits uh from
based on the fact that they know that
you're capable that they just want to
set you up for success ongoing
on that on that particular part so that
has been really
really great experience for me so far
nice and abiola you mentioned the
certificate in public management
uh we have a question here from grace
about how does stanford support folks
who are looking to work in the nonprofit
world
so i can share a couple of uh resources
and then we'll open it up to the panel
for how they've
seen people working in the nonprofit
social impact space kind of taking shape
on campus
we do offer a loan forgiveness program
for folks who are working in the
nonprofit space
so that is a wonderful opportunity um to
really think about how can i be a leader
in any field that i'm interested in
especially that non-profit space
and not have to worry too much about
like what does that debt burden look
like how am i going to pay it back we
need leaders in
all fields regardless of what potential
incomes might be
another really great resource is our
center for social innovation
and so they are a wonderful hub for
different resources
programs alumni networks that can really
get you connected and even provide
additional sources of funding internship
opportunities
uh and connections and networking to
help um accelerate your
your career in that front and so we're
dropping a couple of
links uh in the chat as we speak about
those resources
but for anyone on the group can you talk
a little bit more about like how you've
seen
folks interested in impact or uh kind of
making that change in the world come to
life on campus
um i can i can offer a couple of
examples
so the i think beyond what you talked
about in terms of the center of social
innovation i think
um for graduating
um mba 2 students they also have a
chance to apply for
a fellowship i want to say it's the
apricol fellowship maybe i'm
maybe it's the wrong one so you might
need to look at
whether it's the right one um but there
is a fellowship available for those that
are interested
in uh in starting their own social
innovation ventures
and it helps to fund i think a year
of operations for the person to kind of
explore the model
set it up and so one of one of my
classmates
took advantage of that set up a
financial
uh financial literacy and savings um
platform
targeted at lower income um
individuals here in the us and so he was
able to get a lot of support from that
program for
from the sense of social innovation to
get this venture up and running
um for the last several years so that's
that's the other example
throughout there and um and yeah and if
i'm calling it the wrong thing
please correct me but i think that's
what it's called
and then josh i saw you hopped on as
well
yeah i guess i could jump in there i was
actually going to mention the abuco
fellowship so yes you got the name
karaki
um i think currently there's also chan
fellowship that supports social
ventures they're actually just
a lot so in terms of
the curriculum that supports you to be
able to think through
um what you actually want to do and
refine
both strategy um your mission
and then in terms of practical
experiences to actually allow
you test out some of your theories in
terms of connection to alumni who have
gone before you
in many of these
pathways you are definitely not going to
be left
alone with any of these ideas i think
stanford's
change lives change organizations change
the world
um just comes to mind here like um they
need to talk so
if you're interested in social
innovation i actually do think this is
the place to be
and so we talked a lot about coming to
the gsb
looking forward what's coming next
i think something that um is also really
important that we
is very special to individuals is how do
you maintain
the connections and relationships with
the people you had
before coming to the gsp so here is a
question from fatogo about
how did you manage to stay in contact
with your friends and family in your
home countries
even with a significant time difference
any tips recommendations
reflections on how you were able to
maintain uh
those connections
uh maybe i'll start with mine because
mine is
more recent than the other panelists and
then they could
jump on um i think like almost
everything in life
when you want something um you just need
to dedicate a little bit of effort and
time to it i will not lie it is
sometimes
incredibly isolating and especially in
africa where we have morphe coming out
culture
where i was used to just walking down
the road just knocking on my friend's
door
and kicking it in and saying hey i want
to sit on your couch um
serve me i don't want to cook you feed
me today you know
just stuff like that um so this is a
very different
um
[Music]
atmosphere you know we're more calendar
driven here and
you actually quite you have quite a lot
of deliverables to
to do so um in terms of how i have kept
in touch
um by reckoning with the time difference
and
maybe setting apart an hour or two
before bed
when i can actually
yeah just call people that i want to
speak to or even scheduling those
conversations beforehand
i had to embrace other
social media means i'm not a heavy
social media user
in fact i tend to want to detoxify from
it regularly
but i've realized that some people are
more accessible on facebook some people
are more accessible via instagram and
um blah blah blah so i literally had to
embrace it just so that i could
you know keep in touch with my um
circles and then sometimes just the
basic text
message i think when absence makes the
heart grow fonder
and i think even for you who is a bad
people on the continent your community
will be thinking more of you because
they think hey you are in a different um
place and so anytime they just hear from
you it's just um
fantastic so um i'm curious to hear
if michelle and adioda tried other means
of
maintaining connections with their
communities
no i think you i think you hit on all of
them i will say i think things have just
gotten so much easier with
whatsapp and just being able to do
whatsapp calls
in most cases you know as long as data
is is
cheap and free in your home country i
think it's it's probably
been a much easier way for me to stay in
touch with my family nowadays versus for
example like when i was in undergrad
when you had to buy like a scratch card
and you know
you you get like ten dollars and it's
gone in like 10 minutes so
so thing i think the technology in terms
of staying in touch has definitely
improved so
everything that josh joshua mentioned i
think it makes it that much easier
you just have to be intentional about
finding the time to to connect with your
family and friends back home
well i think i think i don't have to
repeat what
joshua joshua and michelle has said i
think it's the same for me too
just that uh because uh most times well
almost every time i'm homesick i do good
i visited nigeria like a couple of times
during my program
just also to you know stay in touch and
then you know
there are so many support and travel
supports that you can get
from school to actually do these trips
and then i think i was able to leverage
a couple one or two of them in term of
like getting subsidized tickets
uh flight ticket to nigeria and all of
that so i did that there was
a program that also took me so i did the
i think is the seed program
they also took me to africa and i used
the opportunity to also
you know visit nigeria so you get all
those opportunities to in addition to
you know staying in touch with your
family uh
to be ourselves internet is very is free
and everywhere at stanford so you don't
have any problem
to connecting to your family on the
other end i think like michelle has said
now
things are getting really um data is
becoming internet data is becoming
really cheap now
even on the other side which is africa
here where we are so
the flow of communication should not be
as much troubling as it used to be in
the past
and focusing on today's topic from
africa
to stanford we have a question here from
evie
um about what do you think were some of
your contributions
to the gs community um
and if relevant how does like elements
of your african identity
how might that have contributed or what
are some of the perspectives
um any thoughts or experiences on times
that you've seen
kind of that side show up and contribute
to
what was going on at the moment
i think i can depend on this i know that
there are a couple of classes where a
lot of the
cases that were doing were pretty much
like um focusing on
another region and then a lot of the
conclusions
are very different from what you would
what's obtainable on the continent for
example
so you coming in as an african to chip
in
into the class hey wow this is really
why this is brilliant
but it beats a different world entirely
where i come from
and then getting them to know about this
new experience
that um that is not obtainable in most
part most other part of the
world is really really really fulfilling
and it also gets them to really be
very interested in africa for example if
i can really recall i think one of the
classes were doing was had to do with
um uh social innovation financing
and then there was something that we
were doing uh
the the conversation was around uh
financing
uh social innovation in i think it was
india or something but then
the case was totally if you put that in
the context of nigeria for example
actually from my experience with working
uh with the
uh low-income uh environment it was a
bit different
and we had to have to give that
perspective and it became
a full-blown conversation in the class
afterwards so these are like
ways to which you can actually like show
your uh your
experience of being african in class
there are other
ways to which you can do it the africa
business club for example organize
uh organizes uh the africa business
forum every year
and then you get to participate use your
network to invite uh
really interesting speakers to the
panels and also the
uh the program the as keynote speakers
for the for the forum itself
and then people from other continents i
have
i had like a lot of my friends from
every
part of the world coming for the forum
and actually gaining so much from the
speakers
that probably they would have
encountered uh
if they even know for the abf conference
for example so
at least those are the two ways that i
can think of right now maybe joshua and
michelle can also check in on that
yeah one of my favorite tools in in
conversations like
uh those case studies or stuff at work
where i'm like i have a different
perspective
yes and i'm going to jump in that way
so michelle go ahead yeah i think uh if
you don't give a lot of great examples
of how you bring
you know your experiences your network
into the classroom into the campus
environment i think the other way
is essentially connecting people to
your classmates or even your professors
to people
on the continent depending on what
they're working on so let's say for
example they're looking to do a case on
uh on a company on the continent in a
specific sector a lot of times they'll
reach out to students
either through the africa business club
or just generally to just say hey
you know what companies should we be
should we be working with should we be
partnering with
if people are looking for internships on
the continent that's another way that
you know depending on the country that
um that they're interested in you can
also offer perspective you can offer
introductions
and then the last piece i think this was
probably more pre-covered but maybe
we'll come back post-covered
is all the gst so these are the global
um the global trips the global study
trips
that at the oregon i guess you you
enjoyed one of those way you're so
excited
um but this these are essentially trips
that happen
every every semester that that students
organize and
you know as a group you decide which
countries you want to
explore your expose your classmates to
so you know during i think my second
year
a group of students organized a trip to
uh i want to say uganda and rwanda
there's been trips to i want to say
kenya and south africa
uh there's i think been interested in
organizing trips in nigeria i don't know
if it ever happened if you didn't please
hold me
hold me up yes
awesome yeah so so that's another great
way i think
as as african students where you're able
to really showcase what business means
on the continent what leadership means
on the continent
to your classmates who otherwise would
not have that exposure
i guess um there's not much to add um
i can echo everything beyond michelle
has said
but to that i also add that um there's a
culture of small group dinners
here at the gsb and
um to the extent you like to cook you
could actually just
invite people to get a taste of
africa from you and you might also be
willing to screen one or two movies you
feel uh
very typical and depictive of your
reality in africa
it's also this was something that
happened in my first year
and i think a lot of people took a lot
of learnings from
away from that so that's also something
that you put that so there are just
many ways by which you can actually
contribute to
um the gsb community as south africa
ah now yeah yeah miss jsb so much right
now
there's also the part there's this
international food
uh uh day or something where you get
food from a different part of the world
i still remember my plantain that fried
is it's the best that
people were literally convinced to do it
again you know
so there is so much fun being an african
at gsb
uh you you don't want you don't even
have an idea at all
like now i'm missing jsb so bad i think
i should visit sometime soon
oh you better come back and you you're
gonna make me some plantains and i will
you gotta teach me because i love some
good plantain
yeah who are you doing i got you a lot
yes actually i've been hearing something
you made me you're totally right i think
it's a lot of fun being an african on
the continent and
and i think a lot of it is you're
meeting so many people from all over the
world
but you're meeting a lot of other
africans and guys we're so much fun
whether it's like within the africa
business club events whether it's just
hanging out
whether it's just being able to just
relax and talk in whatever accents
without
necessarily people wondering if they can
hear you
there's i think a big enough community
that's been built over time where you
just have a sense of home and sense of
comfort that
you know maybe on a day-to-day basis
when you're in classes when you
when you're in other experiences you
don't necessarily have that but
i feel like the at least when i was at
gsb the african community was pretty
tight-knit where you really felt like
it was essentially your like place to
come and relax
and just you know kick it and and just
be comfortable with
with uh with your fellow africans so
don't let us also forget to mention
center for african studies
just in case you've seen so much of your
of your
gsb african brothers you can actually go
to the center for african studies
where you meet africans uh that
undergrad mostly another post grad
uh come together to have evening nights
discussing everything about africa
is also like a really good resource
where you can meet
africans in the larger stanford
community
at in a particular place you know they
do programs
invite people from the continent to
speak on different topics also
and then joshua i see jumped on here
there's a question
i think can be really helpful as people
are getting excited about the gsb and
comparing especially if they're educated
on the continent like
how do you engage in some of these
conversations in the classroom
in a in a way that's you know productive
and constructive
yeah i was just going to type that that
is actually what is expected
um um the gsb does not just
um argue for diversity and inclusion
just as a catch phrase or as a buzzword
but because
research shows that it actually leads to
better decisions so
better some more creativity you know all
of that
and the whole essence of going for a
diverse class
is to ensure that there's a diversity of
opinions when
issues are being discussed so as long as
you are cognizant of the
impact of your words on those listening
to it
you are expected and invited
to challenge any emotions that you
disagree with
um it takes some learning doing it
differently from
our roots learning system in nigeria and
i guess a lot of africa but after some
time you get the hang of it
you are we're all smart people you got
into stanford after all
um so it doesn't take a few weeks
um you might need to refine and
sometimes choose your battles because
sometimes you realize that the point
you're trying to make has been made
already
or you're literally just killing a dead
horse
with um with more guns but
um yeah it's something that stanford
actually
invites you to do i i also like to
mention this experience i had you know
so
back in nigeria and i'm sure you shall
kind of test this
uh you you then probably talk back at
your professor in class
all you probably do is oh take you take
note of all of these things
and then and then shifting from that
perspective to
where you actually scored for having
conver
like really good conversation in class
it's also like another one i had to
struggle with at the beginning
i forgot to mention that it was you in
fact i had to go and have one-on-one
uh you know sessions with the professors
to say okay how do you
how do you do that and do it really well
you know
so uh it's something you also have to
have at the back of the mind if you are
coming to just be
that hey leave all of those all right we
can you can approach professors
they are they're going to be we have
professors who invest in
student ideas so it can go as far as
that
you know so you're going into a culture
where
you must have really good conversation
with your professors
and that conversation in class where
students literally you know
change professor's perspective on what
he's teaching and he was so smooth
everybody was happy in the end it was
really very encouraging you know
for for the classes so you should be
hoping enough
have the mind that you're going in to go
and have really good conversations and
form relationships and friendship with
your professors
rather than having a hostile uh you know
relationship with them
nice thank you um oftentimes those like
the small like learning tips and
experiences and like
expectations that don't always get
conveyed to like that was
i think going to be really helpful for
folks regardless of what schools they
might end up that here
and so i am actually going to claim the
honor of the last question we are
getting close on time as
you put yourself back in your shoes of
being an
applicant to business school
what advice would you give to your
younger self whether it is about the
application
or even about business school any advice
that you would give
your younger self and joshua maybe we
can start with you
that is actually a very interesting
so the way i thought about it um reading
up all of the resources on business
school
i decided that there are four categories
of people coming to business school
one there are career switches um
two there are career optimizers so
people who
don't need business school to go up in
their careers but
um business school sort of like adds a
little salt and flavor
think of maybe people in private equity
who are going back to private equity
and then there are those who are
defining their careers so career
finance especially entrepreneurs who
know
they have the entrepreneurial drive but
don't have a product yet
something like that and then there are
career advances
those want to advance their career so
maybe think of those who are in
healthcare administration
and want to become this year for some
healthcare company
so i think my i was a career switcher
and so i was pivoting and so my advice
would probably
apply best to those that are switching
careers
and it is come with an open mind
um you are you're almost going to be
starting from scratch
and to a certain extent you're even two
years post business school you're going
to just be
you're still going to be in business
you're still going to be learning a lot
about um the new place so basically
the mindset you had when you were in
college when you could absorb a lot more
information
listen more rather than respond you know
find the best ways to absorb information
and process
it um i'd say that
the mindset you should come with but
with regards to the application process
itself
i think the most important advice i'd
give is to start early
and feel forward and feel quickly so
the more you iterate the more chances
you have to get it correctly but if you
allow analysis to paralyze you
then suddenly you wasted a year just
thinking oh how can i how can i am i
am i and at the end of the day you won't
be able to
um get it done as fast i'm concerned if
you're thinking about business school
then you should be applying to business
school
so i guess that's my um piece of advice
hope it's helpful michelle if you could
go next please
yeah i think i'll build on what joshua
said and i think
the most you know important first take
the first step that you have to take is
actually apply
so i think it's really easy to get into
your head and to have a lot of doubts
and to think that you know the only
people who get into gsb
or any of these top schools are like
super geniuses and i don't think i'm a
super genius maybe joshua and
you guys are super geniuses but
at the end of the day like if you don't
give yourself the
the shot right if you don't apply you're
essentially taking yourself out of the
game
before you've even been considered so i
think it's normal to have doubts
it's normal to think that some of these
schools are out of
our range and out of our reach but you
have to
overcome that and just put in the
application put your best
foot forward and you might be surprised
then you actually get in
um so i think that's the first thing the
second thing
in terms of just the mindset of applying
i i really like how joshua put it i like
those different categories i think i
could see myself
in in one of them but for me the the
other important thing about business
school is you have to think
long term so it's really easy to think
about you know is this
experience going to help me get into
this job after
um right after business school or you
know is it going to help me start a
company right after business school
you know is it is it that straight
linear path and
a lot of time a lot of times in life
things are not linear and so you have to
think
long term in terms of both the
application but also in terms of the
choice of school that
uh you want to you want to attend
and the experience that you end up
having there in the sense of
and this goes back to what i mentioned
in the beginning a lot about business
school is the relationships that you
form and the network that you
build and that's really what's going to
carry you for the rest of your career
regardless of
uh which industry you end up in with
regardless of
uh whether you end up working for a
corporate employer or starting your own
company
you know i'm five years out of business
school right now and the number of times
i've been able to tap
into my alumni network both from up from
my class
as well as other classes to move to move
and navigate different
you know across different companies is
is more than i can count so that's the
other piece to keep in mind with
business school is
you know think long term in terms of the
value when i get from it it's not
necessarily just
that first job or first step out of
business school is
long term if i think i want to move back
to africa if i think i want to
you know go to europe if i think i want
to start my own company
you know is this experience going to set
me up for that and
if if if if the answer is yes then it's
going to be worthwhile
thank you and abiola take us home
yes um okay so i think um i i don't have
much to say and he said
almost every day but then there's all
that another part of it is
the uh buckets that joshua created we
can actually do two at the same time
because i felt like i did try at the
same time so
i switched kaia and also advanced uh you
know so it depends on where you are
when you want to take and but for for me
i still find really very surprising
about applying to stanford
on what matters most to me i literally
just wrote
out my life
and my like what's really like i
remember
crying and writing my essays you know so
i would advise that you should
you should do internal reflection you
know it should be from your heart like
i have i i still can't remember two
people giving
feedback and say this essay would nev
you would not get through stuff
but because i was like oh i i hear oh
you know let it be
from your heart let me try it if it
doesn't work then fine
i mean and then it worked i only applied
once and it worked you know so
for a lot of the process tran you know
internalized a lot of these
questions that you'll be asked and just
write purely from
your heart you are unique you are you're
just one person
in the class so you you and for you to
have been accepted
you're bringing in a very unique
perspective into the class
so try and think inward don't say
because somebody said be right he wrote
this i say in this fashion
that's how you must do it no that's not
how it is it's
being your true self bringing your true
self into the application that matters
on i think the other part is also like
you said
the alumni uh network is is unbelievable
like
even in africa for example we have young
and vibrant alumni
really doing like really good things in
and i'm sure if
i start mentioning a lot of them a lot
of people who relate to them taiyo vilsu
ceo of paga is one i'm sure everybody
knows pagan video in nigeria you
definitely love paganitopia too
i think you should know paga like you
have um
jj ceo rich and he's doing really good
stuff in
financial analysis and apps and all that
so there are a lot of them
uh tammy just built like one of the uh
the state at um hospital
in lucky lagos i ever cared i'm sure a
lot of people would never care
in lagos she's also
an alumna so these people are there as a
resource for you to explore
for sure and if i'm entirely into what
michelle said
whether you're thinking of going back to
africa whether you're thinking of even
starting your own company in africa
they're there for you to use i've
reached out to them
especially on when i was trying to
navigate
a particular like um uh government uh
work yeah and i had to reach out to the
child to say
i know you sat on this policy
deliberation before how did you got did
he go
and he was able to advise me and i
literally put all of that in the
document and
wowed everybody that actually listened
to what i was saying so these are the
things
you can get from the network so i think
i'll handle that
thank you so much to our panelists
i had i had the honor of having a great
time thank you so much to all of our
attendees regardless of where in the
world you are tuning in from
it was a wonderful opportunity to share
time and space with you
uh we hope to see you over the course of
the summer we have a ton of different
events focused on different topics
related to your journey your application
and your stanford so with that have a
wonderful evening
and i hope to see you all again soon
take care